mcconnell bush gop establishment working
to fold trump endorsed candidates senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell's
working behind the scenes to protect and
strengthen gop establishment figures
sometimes in direct opposition to former
president trump and mcconnell isn't
alone either as his side at least one
instance is former president george w
bush one such case in arizona senate
race trump has been highly critical of
governor doug ducey over the state's
performance in 2020 election while ducey
has demurred on running for senate in
2022 he's gotten encouragement from the
likes of mcconnell and george bush
mcconnell has stated that he believes
that trump has uh done damage to the gop
and told allies told allies that he will
not be back unelectable goofballs in the
primaries
what do you have to say about that
are you surprised no not surprised at
all i mean that's the the swamp hates
president trump and they hate anyone
who's not going to conform who's not
going to go and fall in line
i do think that
we need to make sure that we're vetting
candidates and make sure that we have
solid ones that are going to be there
and i think the president has i think
president trump has a smarter more
robust effort
built around him for this time for what
candidates he's backing as and look
there'll be some places where you see
uh you know the the swamp type folks
plus trump being on the same page on
some of these endorsements there'll be
places where they're on different so so
say trump runs 2023 okay
and by the way right now if you bet a
hundred dollars in vegas uh on the bed
of trump running the return is only a
dollar yeah i was going to say that
because everybody says
yeah
but but say he runs who do you see
because what i'm what i'm interested in
is give me a list of people that are his
enemies that we know of and then give
the potential unexpected enemies that
will fight against him not being
president so let's talk about the people
that we know are enemies is mainstream
uh going to support him well and
mainstream as maybe a wrong word that i
used i'd say the the washington uh the
swamp creatures they're not going to
support them they're not going to
support it okay um i do think that the
the overall republican base is pretty
solidly with trump so so go to the swamp
give me names on the right that you
would consider swamp mcconnell's one
yeah mclaughs would you put a swamp uh i
mean you go into i mean you listed
number earlier whether we've mcconnell
whether it be rove i know where it might
technically live in in texas but he's
viewed as being kind of the
establishment that
george w bush types uh that are there um
i would say
anyone who voted in the liz cheney types
even though she's going to be out of
office here there's zero chance that she
wins her her race in wyoming uh but
those are the types got it so so number
one number of commerce the the the
chamber of commerce the swamp
is not going to support him on the right
who else will be those that wouldn't
support him that would fight him tooth
and nails to make sure he doesn't get
elected well and so this word starts to
get a little bit more stilted i think
it's tough to say that there's
the law enforcement and the legal system
has not become politicized against
president trump when you look at say the
state of new york you look at tisch
james you look at some of these
activists attorneys general
i think it's become very politicized i
think the fact that tish james ran in
2018
saying that she was going to lock up
president trump this is the attorney
general of the state of new york
campaigning saying i'm going to win and
then we're going to lock up donald trump
what kind of impartial law enforcement
activist
is this i mean this thing is is so
politicized that i i think it's really
just an
egregious abuse of our uh our judicial
system so you can say but then i'd also
say
and this kind of goes to i know another
thing we're going to talk about
you look what they did with trump with
all the the spying and the data
collection and things like that from
2016 and even beyond i don't put it
above even biden's white house or
biden's doj
to go and pull some of the same
shenanigans again okay so so far we got
the swamp a part of the mainstream media
you got uh some of the uh government the
uh
police or the lincoln project crew steve
schmidt all those guys then the last one
you just talked about here with what's
gonna happen potentially joe biden
similar thing to what happened with the
durham investigation hillary pulled off
obama gate to maybe biden doing that uh
who else you think will be you think do
you think the facebooks of the world you
think those guys are going to be overly
playing the control game to make sure
not necessarily trump they've already
done that but other people that are
coming up hey candace owens that all of
a sudden does alive and gets 22 million
views well let's silence her you think
there's going to be a lot more stories
like that happen the next couple of
years absolutely here's one that kind of
the the buried leads or untold stories
the progressive left really took it out
on jack dorsey and mark zuckerberg after
trump won in 2016. and they said it's
because of you you guys came up with
those platforms you allowed trump to
evade the media go directly to people
it's on you i think that's a big part of
the reason why you saw zuckerberg then
go and fund some of the election efforts
uh with the drop boxes and the things of
that nature kind of the good is he would
probably probably describe a good
government and pro-voting but he
basically was funding he knew what he
was funding um but the uh
that's why you saw so much of the
backlash they changed the rules of the
game in 2020 they said okay trump you're
not gonna have the unfettered access
we're gonna suspend you where necessary
we'll put up the warning labels and now
post election they ultimately banned
them from their accounts so i think that
will ratchet up even higher and that's
part of the thing you look at again not
where the ball is right now but where
it's going is we go into these elections
not just the 2022 midterms or even 2024.
facebook and twitter have already made
that business decision that they want
some people as customers and others they
don't want as customers not just in the
us but around the world
they're both of those platforms are
going to lose tremendous amounts of
people as they come in and exercise
additional acts of political
discrimination well we saw that when
they lost 240 billion in a day facebook
that's a lot of money to lose in a day
240 in a single day so who
who will be the supporters go on the
flip side now who will be the supporters
and who will be the surprising
supporters so one and again there's
you're probably already aware of this
one i think latinos and hispanic
americans will be big drivers for trump
and part of the reason is this
democrats made a just a fundamental
miscalculation when they backed the blm
movement the way they did in 2020 that
just with the the lawlessness and the
the acts of looting and everything that
that we saw come out of those those
rights and protests
i think that you have a lot of white
democrats in washington who don't
understand the hispanic and latino
american communities at all and think
it's purely just about economics you
travel to central and south america and
people have eight nine foot walls around
their house or eight nine foot gates and
and walls and and uh fences things of
that nature it's because it's not safe i
mean go to columbia and even good
neighborhoods you have the the uniformed
officers with with machine guns uh it's
because of the challenges they've had
it's not just about economics it's also
about security people want to live in a
place where their kids can walk to
school without being potentially
abducted or killed or shot or something
of that nature and by democrats
embracing the blm movement they i think
they did a generation worth of damage to
their relationship with the latino and
hispanic american communities and you
saw that not just
in the rio grande i think latino
americans would be the surprising driver
for trump i also think too
look trump got a lot of people forget
this trump did record setting well for
with latino americans black americans
asian americans best ever for a
republican since 1972 and i think that
movement by african americans away from
the democratic party whether they be
going to independence or going to
republican i think that's continuing
because quite frankly i don't think
democrats would make good on their
promises to black americans at all so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]